次に出てくるのはこの水道心という心
三つありますし この水道心
三つっていうのは この入った情報も基本的な処理しなくちゃいけない
貪瞋痴で処理するんじゃなくて
まあいいものか悪いものか
そうでないものかと 貪瞋痴で関係なくもう分けなくちゃいけない
それは水道心と呼ぶんですね
それは入った情報を分類する
主観的な分類ではないんです
例えばもう聞きたくない強烈な音が入ったら
音自体が人間には聞きたくない音だから
水道心はそれは悪い方に分析するけど
これもなんか果物なんか選ぶ時と同じなんですよ
買う時ではなくて 果物農場で分類するでしょうに
で 重いものはこっちと軽いものはこっちと
いろいろ傷あるものはこちらと
で ベルトで果物を並べてくると
こちらとこちらとこちらでそうやって分けてるだけのことで
そこにあるのは情報によって分けるんであって
我々買う時はそうじゃなくて
自分の主観的なもので選ぶんですね
その選び方とこちらで言ってる選び方は違います
水道心の選び方は 水道心というのはサンティーラなチッタというんですけど
この選べてしまっちゃいますね
そこで次にそれ三つあります
次に出てくるのは確定心なんですね
で 確定心ではその決まったことをそこで確定するんですよ
あ こういうものだと 生えた情報が生えた音がいい音だと確定する
それは瞬時に起こるんです
そこで確定したところから
人間の主観的な世界が生まれてくるんです
例えば いくらいい音入っても人がそれに怒ったりする可能性ありますよ
それはもう人間の主観的な世界で
本当は人間聞いてはいけない悪い音かもしれませんだけど
それは気持ちよく聞くこともできる場合もありますし
それは主観的な世界 まあそういうことで十八種類あります
無因心は この無因心の十八種類の場合
無因心というのは不貪不瞋痴と貪瞋痴とは関係ないということだけで
ただ働きとして生まれるだけです
他の心は分けられます
で七十三ページにこのモームーハチッターニエーカヘトゥカーニと書いて
このあの貪瞋心には一因であるとかね
国具心と書いてます そこはね
貪瞋心じゃなくて何 痴根
痴根心と前あったんだけどね
こちら国具心と書いてますが
それはモーハムーラチッタなんですね
不善心の中にあの最後にあった二つなんですね
それは無知だけで 不善心の残り十は二因ですね
で 善心の世界では智慧がある心には三因
智慧がない心で世界では二因
不善の世界で悪の世界では無知の心は一因
欲の心は二因 怒りの心は二因
それだけ で あのまあ大体大雑把に理解すればいいんです
そこで厳密に解釈できますけど
厳密に解釈する場合は
皆様方はちゃんと暗記して置いておかないと
心相と心はもうきちんと暗記して
いろいろ分類カテゴリーを覚えておかないとやりにくいんですよ
だからそれはそれで別に役に立つかどうかといったってもね
もう役に立たない可能性もあるし
浄土論やらね 注釈書やらね
ご自分で読んで理解したいと思うならば
いくらか助けになるかもしれませんだけどね
経典勉強する場合は別にそんなに必要じゃないんですね
[笑い]しっかり知ってる人にとっては瞑想するとかなりの幅広く物事は見えてきますよ
それは人に指導する時やら説法する時やら役に立つんであって
説法したいという気持ちなければね
別にそこまでする必要はないし
といってもやっぱり自分の修行はいくらかうまくいっちゃうと
どうしてもその智慧がつきますよ
人に教えられるぐらいの智慧っていうのは
それはつきます 自分の言葉で語れますから
それはそんなにも問題じゃないんです
こういう世界なぜ現れたかというと
我々はこの他の部派仏教やら大乗仏教やらね
そういう世界は滅っていっちゃったんだから
もう徹底的に知識的な論理的な土台を作っておかなくちゃいけなかったんです
純粋な仏教を守るために
で まあ鎧と言うんですかね
戦争に行くと昔被ったものはね
それは鎧一つ被ったような感じで
それでいくらか身を守られるんだと
結局それ被っちゃったら歩けない
動けないということもありますけどね
だからこういうことばっかり勉強するようになっちゃったら
その分もうかなりきつくて硬くはなりますよね
だから戦争に出なきゃいいんです
戦いに 戦いに出なきゃ
もう楽にそのまま生きていられる
戦いに出る人はやっぱりただ行っちゃったらもう矢に撃たれて死んじゃいますから
ものすごいきつく自分を守るためにいろいろ鎧を被らなくちゃいけない
ですから この仏教の専門家の世界では
いろんな宗派が出てきたら
お釈迦様の教えは壊しちゃいますから
例えば大乗仏教では釈尊はないでしょうに
完全に殺してるんだからね
釈迦様はどこにも現れない
全部どこかの化物の話でしょうに
じゃあ法華経 法華経ですか
あれが誰が喋ったんですかね
いろいろ化け物たちが喋ったんだってならば
何も喋ってないでしょうに
由井真賢にしたっても
どこら辺の知らないじじいが喋ってるだけで
お釈迦様も現れないし
弟子たちも現れないでしょうに
ですから 順番に釈尊を追っ払って
自分たちの世界を作ってるんですよ
それはものすごい巧みにやってるんだから
それぐらい厳密に巧みに初期仏教を守る人々も頑張らなくちゃいけなくなっちゃったんです
だから鎧作りだけ作っちゃうんじゃなくて
向こうからもう戦いを作って戦ってくるんだから
身を守るしか方法なかったんです
ですから すっごいうるさいほどきめ細かいんですよ
この定義にしたって ものすごいもう嫌になるほど定義なんですね
もう 定義の法則やら 特に定義の法則っていうのは
この文章は能動的受動的
的という 2種類ありますね
で 決まってるんです 定義は能動的にするもんじゃないんだと
能動的にすると主語あるんですね
例えば心の定義は知る機能が心であると
知る働きは いわゆる知られる働きは心であると
知ることは心でありますよと言ったら
そこでなんとなく微かに誰かが知る
そのそこまで気をつけるんですよ
別に文法的にはパッシブボイスっていうのをあまり使ってはいけないんですよ
そうするとわからなくなっちゃうんです
人間はもういつでも主語で物事私がいて
相手がいてという実体論でいるんだから
例えば英語で文章を書く場合は決まってるんです
パッシブボイスはやめろと
文法的にはありますよ
ちゃんと主語があって
動詞があって だからとにかくたまにパッシブボイス使いたい場合もあるかもしれません
どこかに行ったらもう虫に刺されたんだと
で その後英語でもね  I was beaten or attacked or beaten by mosquitoes という
というのはパッシブでしょ？パッシブボイスでしょ
それよりは英語を喋る人にとっては Mosquitoes attacked me というのは分かりやすいんだそうです
あるいは他の attackedではなくraged me とかね
punched me 何でもいいんです
Army of mosquitoes punched me, raged me 何でもいい
その時はもういろいろ文法的に文学的にいろんな
でもとにかく ACTIVE VOICE なんですね
ACTIVE VOICE の能動的な場合は
やっぱり誰かがいて何かをするということになっちゃうし
主動の場合は誰かがいるんじゃなくて
働き自体があって何かなったということなんですね
そこで定義を 仏教の定義の場合は全てこの主動的な
能動的ではなくて主動的な言葉でしなさいと決まっちゃったんだけど
なかなかいつでもうまく定義できなくなっちゃうんですね
言語学的ないろいろ問題もありますから
そこで能動的な定義しながらも
またどこかで まあこういう風にも理解できます
こういう風にもと また気をつけちゃうんですね
そこまで気をつけるんですよ
実体論を避けるために
ほんのそこまでやらなくてもいいんだけど
やっぱり周りのもう関係ある関連ある宗教の方々はもう徹底的にこの個体を主体をあるということで頑張ってるんだからね
そちらの方が力強いんです
人間の理解は まあ主体があって動詞があった方が理解しやすいんだから
だからまあ普通には普通の一般に仏教を勉強する人々には
それはそんなに必要な世界じゃないんですね
そこで大学で研究する人々にとっても別に関係ないことなんですよ
大学でそういうことを研究したってもいいんだけどね
あんまりそこまで頭がね
咲いてないんだからね
なんとかテキストいじってなんとか書くだけのことだからね
ただたくさん資料を集めて並ぶと
で この間ある まあもう先生のね
まあすごい厳密に書く先生なんです
本を読んでみたんだけど
あれ文章を書くためには
あの先生若い時からもう 50歳
60歳になるまでずっと研究なさって
それでもうやっと書いてるんです
他の本もいろいろ書いてましたけど
その自分で書いたかったことというこうして書いてますけどね
ただ厳密に資料集めてるだけなんですね
僕は読んだのはこの無期の部分なんですけど
で 無期は 10種類あるんだと
ある経典で ある経典で 8種類あるんだ
ある経典で 12種類あるんだと言って
このパーリ経典で無期の説が出てくることをつって並んでカテゴリにして
こういうこういう ABCDE と F まであるんだと
それから漢文ではもうあるところ全部まとめて並んであって
そこまで探すためにはかなり時間かかるんだけど
結局あんた何言いたがってるんですか？そういう
なんのね で 結論としては
このもう漢文ではきちんと無期の 12 まできちんとまとめて分けてますけど
パーリ経典ではそうじゃなくて
これぐらいあって そこでもしかするとこういうこういうわけで10になってるかもしれません
でもまあ 10 というのはより古くて
仏教的に見れば正しいんだと
という結論が出せてますけど
ただそれだけ なぜ無記ですか
なぜ答えないですかと答えてはないんですね
それにもう中村先生はそれについてこういう言葉を言ってるんだと
で それはその通りですよ
それで終わっちゃうんですね
それだったら黙ってればいいのに
中村先生すでに答えているんだから
だから中村先生って本当に哲学フィロソファーだから
もうただ無記の部分を読んで
あ こういうことだと自分の観察を書いてるんですよ
ですから まあそれは役に立ちますけどね
ある哲学者が自分の感想を言ってるんだから
ある教えについて 研究者には役に立たないなとね
あれは皆様にも読めないと
まあテキストはこういうテキストだと言えますけどね
こういう先生だと言えますが
読めないと思いますよ
私が読んでも 私はまあその
そういう そういう専門だからね
読めますけどね ですから
この厳密にこの分析したり定義したり解釈したりするということは
やっぱりまあそういうまあ専門的な世界で
まあ普通の仏教の方々にはそれほど関係はない
とにかくすごい まあそういう世界ではすごいうるさいんですよ
これ大乗仏教とは大した変わりはないんですよ
あるインターネットで見たんだけど
この何て言いますか 南妙法蓮華経というところで
南無妙法蓮華経っていうのは正しいんだと
そこで南無っていうのはとんでもないことだと
なぜならば 日蓮がその一つの文字が一つの如来だと言ってるんだと
それで南無と言ったら一文字が落ちちゃうんですね
それで如来一人殺したことになるんだと
だからもううるさいことはそれぐらいうるさいんですけど
あれをこんなくだらないうるささじゃないんだけど
こちらでもやっぱり定義する場合はやっぱり主導的な受動という受動ですか
定義に行きなさいと言ったって
もう受動の定義は分からなくて理解できない
例えばパチェリー 地位ですね
あのチーズリカーの地位
で タッデラッカナンとも
硬さが硬さ がパチェリーであると
アーポーハラッカナン
アーポーとまとめまとめる機能
いわゆる引き寄せる その機能に我々はアーポーと呼びというんだよと
本当は水はだから実際しないんですよ
随分気をつけているんです
スビという幻想が水という幻想が実際しない
そこでどんなものでもいいし
引き寄せるという働き
ただの働きだから 別に何のこともないんですね
それはもう厳密に定義するんです
ですから 素粒子論理はアビダンマには全くもう邪道
邪見なんです 素粒子と言った途端
また何かあるという風になっちゃいますから
私はずっと散々使ったんだけど
説明するときは アビダンマではそんなことはもう邪見そのものなんです
ただ硬さ 硬さ それは地の元素
引き寄せることは それは水の元素
膨らめる働きが いわゆる引き離す働きが風の元素
そこで地水火 火でまたちょっと説明しにくくなっちゃうし
で 地と水と風の場合はまあ
まあ手動でいくらかわかりますけど
全部手動の定義で説明できないところはあるんですね
随分まあきめ細かくもう
やってるんです まあそれなりに訳が出ます
はい で 次にあの一応と
なんですか こちらで八書いてる
このキッチャ サヨ キッチャサンガヘキッチャニナーマパティサンディバヴァンガアヴァッジャナ
ダッサンサワナガーヤナサーヤナプサンサンパティッチェナサンテーラナゴッタッバナジャワナタダーラッマナチュティヴァセーナチュッダサヴィダーニバワンティ
で まあここら辺はちょっと理解した方がいいかもしれません
で サヨっていうのは働きなんですね
で 心 心臓 全部まとめて仏教
ここで心って言うんですね
心と心臓がまとめたところですし
まあ離れませんだからね
その一つ一つの心に何か働きがあるんです
心がする働きは全部十四種類なんです
そこでちょっとした問題も生まれます
こういう問題なんですね
例えば十四種類の働きがありますと
心にある心が 例えば四つの働きをしているんだと
四つの仕事 ある心が五つの仕事をしているんだと
ある心は一つの仕事しかしてないんだと
それは人間の世界では分かりやすいんですよ
人間の世界でも 例えばある家族のお母さんが
あの 何て言いますか パートタイムやってるんだと
パートタイムってバイトですか
バイトもやってるんだと
そこでお姑さんでもあるし
母親でもあるし で バイトもやってるし
一人の人がいろいろ働きしてるんですね
そういうことなんです
でもそこで今の私の説明も能動的で主体があるんです
心という主体がいて その主体が働きをする
そういう定義はものすごく嫌われるんですね
上座仏教では でもそういう風に言った方が分かりやすいでしょうし
分かりやすいんだけど
それは間違いだと そうじゃなくて
働きに心というんです
で 心があるわけじゃなくて
働きに心という だからどれほどうるさいかと理解してください
それだけ 例はないんですね
例えば目が見るということは言わない
見られる だから目というんだと
だから見られるという働きが大事であって
あるいは見る でも見られるのは正しいんです
日本語でどう感じるかわかりませんだけど
パーリ語だったら見られるということで
見られるという機能に目という
だから目があって目で見るということをしているんだと
目が見ていると そういうのは言わないんです
[笑い]でもそれを理解すると
この働きfunctionはあって function
にただラベリングしているだけやと
それを理解すると 本当はそれの方が正しいんです
世の中での働きがないと我々のラベリングできないんです
だから例えばこのプラスチックの食べ物ありますね
いろんな店にモデル作って
そこでどれほどあのプラスチックの製品は正確というと
見て区別できないんですよ
例えば本物の魚を焼いて
それから展示するためにプラスチックで作っている魚が焼き魚あるでしょうね
どちらか本物かというと
だいたい誰でももしかするとプラスチックの方を選ぶかもしれません
それぐらい精密には作ってるんです
で まあ匂いではわかるかもしれません
例えばガラスも何かね
もう中に入れちゃって
匂いが届かないようにして
どちらが本物かというとわからないほど精密に作られる
でも我々はこのプラスチックで作っている焼き魚の形には焼き魚と言わないでしょ
なぜならば 焼き魚という言葉でラベルを貼るためには
何か仕事をしてこなきゃ
もらわなきゃ困るんです
その仕事はしてくれないんだから
それをプラスチックだという
もしその仕事をしてくれると
それには本物の焼き魚という
だから本物か偽物かと決める場合は
その仕事をしてくれる場合はそれは本物であって
してくれない場合はそれは本物じゃないんです
そこで世の中にある本物の偽物もまたありますけど
そこで区別区別できなくなっちゃう
なぜならば 偽物なのにも仕事をしてくれると
このブランドのカバンとかバッグとかね
その場合はどっちでもいいんです
だからこのブランド製品の場合は
偽物の方にもちゃんと商売があるんです
なぜなら仕事してくれるんだから
その時はどうでもいいところで判断する
縫い目がまっすぐかとか
幅が均等にあるか それぐらい偽物を作る人にはあれぐらい技術はあるんだからね
それぐらいできるんだから
頑丈かないかと 偽物を作る人にとって頑丈に作ることもできるんだからね
あんなものは決して基準にはならない
それでは間違いの可能性ありますよ
プロでも ですから そこは偽物とは言えない
それは単なるこのブランドの製品をどこかで登録して
これは俺のものだとかね
決めたことだけのことですからね
でも 例えば時計というためには
何か仕事してもらわなきゃ困る
髪の毛というためには何か仕事をしてもらわなきゃ困る
だから世の中のあるすべての言葉であろうか
すべての物であろう言葉があってもなくても
何か仕事をしているんですね
何か働きをしているんですよ
ですから どうせ大事なのはその働きなんです
だから実体的なものがあるかないか
ということじゃないんです
だから働きがあるんだから
我々は実体があると錯覚する
例えば聴覚という働きが生まれるでしょう
聴覚という働きが生まれると体が変化するんです
音が聞くと 変わらへんだから
そこで聴覚という働きが生まれる
それで我々は音というものがあるという言葉で言うだけ
ですから もう存在 存在じゃなくて
実際にこの宇宙であろうか
人間で私であろうか 全てのものには何かFunction
何か働きが いろいろ働きがあるって
それに我々は実体があると
実体あると言うんです
例えば宇宙空間があると思っちゃうでしょうに
なぜあると思っちゃいますかというと
宇宙空間として何か働きをしているんです
もし何の働きもしなかったら
そんなものは存在しない
全然存在しない 何も働きしないものは存在しない
ですから 我々にとって存在するっていうことは働きがあるということで
そこを理解しちゃうと
この実体論からはなんとか身を守ることはできるんですと
音があるかないかっていうのは
聴覚が生まれるか生まれないかということです
形があるかないかっていうのは
視覚が生まれるかないかということだけのこと
絶対人間に視覚が生まれないならば
そこに形があるわけじゃないんです
ということで 人間のすべての知識は人間の眼耳鼻舌身の働きだけの世界ですよ
人間に見えないものを科学者が発見したわけでもないし
人間に聞こえない音を科学者が聞いたわけでも何もないんです
ただ言葉の過ちだけ 例えば目に見えない光があるんだと
それは嘘です 目に見えない光があるわけじゃないんです
ただ あるエネルギーに科学者たちが光と言っただけ
それでエネルギーであることを私はちゃんと知ってますよ
例えばレントゲンのね X
線とかなんとかありますからね
ガンマ線とかああだこうだとか
あるいは赤外線とかね
紫外線とかね 紫外線見えますか？見えるはずがないんですね
そこにもう科学者が光だと決めたんだから
見えない光もあるんだと
世の中でいろんな機械で測れる波動がありますね
その機械で測る波動に音だと決めつけ
決めつけちゃったんですね
そこで超音波と低音波
なんとかなんとかハイフリークエンシ
ローフリークエンシーもう言葉で言えるだけ
それ私やっぱりいろいろ音があるんだけど
人間にもほんのわずかしか聞こえないとかね
言いますけど そこにも見えるのは働きなんですね
だからこの 例えば宇宙にあるエネルギーがあって
それは耳には反応しないんだけど
この機械には反応するんだと
機械にした反応は自分の目で見えると
もし機械に反応しなかったら
科学者にもそれ存在しないでしょう
電子顕微鏡でも反応しないならば
そういうのは存在しない
だから何か働きをするということが正しいんです
何か働きをすることで
それ自身の存在はああだこうだとか
言葉の世界でいろんなことを言ってます
そこで昔から仏教ではこの働くということは働きというFunction
キッチャというのは働きというよりはFunctionですね
何か機能 それで説明していくんです Function
という言葉 機能という働きという言葉を使った途端
存在は動的であって止まっていないということは見えるでしょう
ダイナミックであって
一切は そこで静止論は消えちゃうんです
我々はそういうことで忙しくて
神様がいるかいないかとかね
そんな話には暇がないんです
まああまりにも幼稚というか
ガキ的というかね でもこういう説明をしちゃうと
そういうね 遊びなんかしなくたっても物事済みますよ
どんな神様がいいかどうかね
まあで 神様をまあ神様の彫刻できるかないかとか
もうヒンドゥー教であっても神様の方といろいろあるでしょうしね
もう象の顔をしている神様やら
牛の顔をしている神様
猿の顔をしている神様
そういう世界とはもう離れているんです
ですから 動というね ダイナミックな働きからそれでできる働きは止まることはないんだから
じゃあそこら辺はわかりにくい説明でわかりやすい説明に入ります
そこまで 14 種類の働きは
1番目はパティサンディ
日本語で結生というのですね
で あの結生っていうのはパティサンディのもっと俗的な言葉で言えば
このもう新しく生まれ変わることなんですよ
で まずそういうふうに順番に説明します
一番わかりやすいことは
私は死んだっていうことは
私の心がこの体で止まったっていうことなんですね
心がこの体で止まって
でもまた始まりますね
どこかで それにはそれは結生と言うんですね
結んじゃうんだと このこちらの生き方と
もう一つの生き方 繋げてしまっちゃう
ですから この転生の場合
この日本語で考えているものはもう仏教とは関係ないんで
例えばまあ親が子供を作ったことで
それは転生だと そうすると死ぬ前に自分が生まれ変わってるんですね
そういうことで 仏教の転生っていうのはもう死んでから生まれ変わる
死ななきゃ生まれ変わることはできないんですね
もし自分の孫やら子供やら自分の生まれ変わだと思うならば
自分が死んでいてほしいんだよね
ですから 決して我々の子供たちが我々の誰でもないんです
誰でもないんです そちらはそちらの心の流れが流れを持ってるんです
ただ この体から一部をいただいた
いただいて それで自分でコピーしてコピーしてでっかい体を作っただけですから
ちょっとプログラム一つ借りて貸してあげただけのことで
それでずっと執着しているんですね
あなたは私の子供だと
自分貸してあげたプログラムですから
いくらか似ているだけのこと
それ体は似てるんだけど
心は全然似てないんだから
機械は似てるんだけどね
機能は似てない だからみんなこの機械は本物だと思って
それにも苦労してるんですね
でも自分の子供見たってのは
やっぱり昨日は似ていないと考え方やら生き方やら全く違うと見えるんだから
そこで我が子という執着は消えちゃうんですよ
それ消えたらそれなりにそういう楽なんです
互いに楽なんですよ いじめられたりいじめたりしないんだから
親子同士でも権力を奪ったり奪われたりしないでしょうに
それぞれの生命のね 生命を一人個人として尊重するし
尊重されるし それで出てくるのは
どうすればこの全く別個の生命同士がうまく仲良く共存するかっていうことなんですよ
本当は我々に必要なのはそれなのに
それ忘れちゃうんですよ
自分の子供 自分の奴隷になることじゃなくて
共存することなんですね
うまく互いにぶつからないで
互いの幸福を願って 互いに幸福になるように共存することは正しい幸福ですけど
それを創るためには やっぱり相手は全く別人であると
全く独立した生命であると
ということは認めなきゃ
それ言っちゃうとみんな嫌う
嫌って逃げちゃうんですね
いいえ あの子は私の子供です
それだったら死ぬまで苦しみなさいと
子供には必ずも逃げられますよと
あとはもう病気になって寝たきりになっても
そのあなたの子供 あなたの面倒見てあげないと
そこで親に対するすごい恨みやら怒りやら
もうものすごく出てる
それ全てが執着から生まれて捕まりたい
捕まりたかったんだから
全てが生まれてくるんですよ
そうじゃなくて まあ一応自分がちょっと一部のね
プログラムを貸してあげたんだけど
それにいちいち向き合う権利ないで大したことじゃないんだから
これ 100万円  10万円貸してあげたことと
それぐらいも価値がないんだから
僕から見れば この似てることは体はすごい気持ち悪いんです
自分の弟の男の子がいるんですけど
私は子供は好きですから
本当はすごい可愛がって一緒に遊んであげたいんです
自分にも子供ないんだからね
でも見ると似てもう触りたくもないし
他の人の子供たちが来たら
まあ可愛い可愛いと もう体に乗るは遊ぶはいろんなこと何でもやってあげるんだけど
面倒見てあげる それだったらやっぱりね
自分の弟の子供でもちょっと優しくしてあげてもいいんだけど
なんか気持ち悪いんですよ
それで遺伝似てるんだからもう全部見えてるんですよ
もうだからもうバレてるというかね
他の子供だったら何言ってるんですか？と
何企んでるんですか？ともうここで解読しなくちゃいけないでしょ
あの子もうもう知ってるわ
こうやってるな こういうこと
こういう人はこういうことをやって
もう遺伝で知ってるんだから
遺伝的に自分が自分の全部昔から全部自分のプログラム覚えてるんだから
もう見えたもんなんですね
そうするともう 本当なんか悲しくなっちゃいますけどね
やっぱり優しくしてあげられないんだから
でもやっぱり普通の世界では
それはすごい喜んじゃうんですね
同じコピーだったら で
その場合でも やっぱりこの体は似ていたっても人は違うと
これは全く違う人だと見ると
まあいくらかこの違う人とどうやれば仲良くできるかと
そこで平和な世界が生まれてくるんですよ
やっぱり違うと認めてあげたことは
家庭やら社会の幸福の平和の始まりなんです
ですから この血潮パティサンディっていうのは
やっぱり人が死んだらまた心が繋がれてどこかに生まれると
それは一つの一方の流れなんですね
うん まあそこは一つで
で それは私たちにとっては分かりませんね
だからといって輪廻転生分かったって言ったら
それでは分かるわけじゃないんでしょうし
一つ心の働きはそういう働きなんです
で こういうふうには理解できるんです
輪廻転生は理解できませんだけど
物体があっても生命にはならないんですね
細胞があっても生命にはならないんです
それは生きていなきゃ
ですから この なぜ細胞が生きて生き続けるかというと
そこに心が働き始めるんだからなんですね
働き始めると生き続けちゃう
細胞も成長しちゃうし
この働きが止まったらそこで成長も止まってしまっちゃうんですね
ですからつなげる機能なんですね
血潮っていうのは パティサンディっていうのは
で 私たちの細胞から見ても
細胞は死ぬんだけど 新しい細胞を作ってこの体をつなげてくれるんですね
壊れる壊れるものの代わりに何か作ってつなげてくれる
壊れたものはすべてつなぎ作ってくれるんだったら
人間は全く同じ状態